was going to have so much Intrigue to it the
Oilers a cup favorite for many how the Oilers
will respond tonight is something many are
waiting eagerly to see and as for the Canucks
can they keep the Rick talk game plan going for a
second straight game against McDavid and dry CLE
as this one is officially underway glad to have
all of Canada along with us here as a chance for
the Oilers denied by the Smith kman and Ryan Nan
Hopkins on the prowl right off the Hop here now
is Ryan Nan Hopkins digging for that puck Ian Co
picks it up tried to get it out of the Zone he
was unable to do so CeCe a pass over to Darnell
nurse he shoots it's right in front to Smith
is there and it stayed out dry cdle denied
the puck almost near the line no it's in the
net it started right off the face off with
a little battle between Miller and dry cdle
and they just continue to bash away at this
Puck the Smith with some awesome saves in
this sequence I mean he kept the Pucket of
his net slopping around all over the place
and then finally it's dryy that Taps it home
on the doorstep for a one- nothing lead who
had 18 of their own here's dry cidal now over
to buar from up top to McDavid he's creeping
up mcdavid's pass D on the one tier to
Smith got just enough here's dry Sidle
once again Bard slapper missed on the sent it
out of the Zone himself the Oilers completing
a change Quinn Hughes now stopping in neutral
ice besser dumps it in racing to it is Miller
a shot from pson that's off Target besser crossy
feed was momentarily knocked out by Brown here's
Hughes Miller gets it back to pet now Hughes
has it again Hughes shooting and the connect
score tipped home by Andre kzo and that's
his first of the season this game is tied
at one a piece well it just goes to show
you how important disciplines with these
two teams these two power plays can snap that
puck around and it's kzm playing in front with
a great redirection nice little sauce pass
to find Patterson Brin Hughes again finds
his way to the middle and this is something
he's looking to do a little more this year
let that shot go has traffic in front perfect
tip beat Stuart Skinner and ties this game and
kzo 39 goals last season cycling it laery
takes it pokes it back to the point Myers
delivering ahead hoglander behind the Oilers
that hoglander skips away besser Sho they score
Neils hoglander tips it home and the Canucks
Take the Lead late in the first great shift
again by the Miller line there hem Edmonton in
physical hard shift right will Miller go at it
again he puts this Puck around and it's
besser that just skates right into it
and he gets it to the net hoger
standing in front with the back
end tip similar to the first goal by
kzco get to the front net screen the
the shoulder deflected down into the net 2-1
Vancouver all off the four check 26 to go now
and it seems doable given how refreshed he
looked in the season opener and does again
tonight Scott it was really nice to see how
knocked off the PT Noah Json has he gave it
away dry Sidle has it he's got room D side a
walking in backhand shot to Smith was there
they're still looking for it so front at
the top of the greas with David [Applause]
scars the Oilers Captain with his first of the
season it's a power play marker in this game is
tied at two and the patience of dry settle here
takes it to the back in I think he was looking
back door goes down actually into Ian Cole who
laid down but stay in the scramble similar to the
first goal for Evington k as Skinner got his right
arm on that mle trying to get that puck out fired
near the net a good stop from Skinner in tight
on Garland who's that puck up and Fogo gets it
out of the oiler Zone Conor McDavid extending his
current point streak against the cans to 17 games
now 36 points during that 17 game stretch and
here is Conor here is Warren Fogle part of me
as pu comes all the way over now two on0 for the
kanox all of a sudden Pon a pass a shot and a goal
from STA and the canuts regain the lead just like
[Music] that Darnell nurse knows it too as soon as
that puck turns around they're Off to the Races
great job by patteron to take the middle line
denying nurse of any Lane to try and disrupt and
then put the backand rapist with n and he puts it
back home between the pads of Stuart Skinner and
for Jack stad n got recalled was sent down to the
American Hockey League recalled immediately back
up into the season starting it off that's it back
to McDavid he navigates through hands it off to
Ryan new Hopkins reversing to buard blar to Nan
Hopkins who takes a look moves up Richard
is [Applause] [Music] tying the game once
again it's a laser by Ryan nen Hopkins so many
different looks good job by him to draw laferty
down find Bard and this Lane opens up and instead
of trying to force a pass again uses the screen of
Heron and puts it Far Side pretty difficult
for to Smith to make this save perfect shot
under the glove over the pad 3-3 h from the
middle to buar Evan buar switches spots hands
it off Newan Hopkins creeping up pass down low
hman spinning firing but wide tridal now over to
Newan Hopkins again Bard rtier just with the same
rebound Dy cidal as that one go over top of the
net all right thank you Scott 20
minutes to go here in regulation
game tied at three a piece and a lot of
intrigue in this second matchup of the
season for both of these teams Brown
takes that puck tried to get it back
to his defens cut off by hoglander coming
in with speed laery driving to The N he
scores a third period goahead goal that is Sam
laffer's first as a Vancouver kanuck and it's 4
to three he knows he's going to get hit he knows
he might get knocked down but it's a nice Outlet
pass onto the tape from hoger and he just tucks
the shoulder gets the shot away on a big man
Matas e home playing his first game since last
year but great Puck protection that little move
to kind of tow drag into the inside change the
angle a little bit and then take the shot as he
chips it over the right pad of steuart Skinner in
the Vancouver canx Take the Lead once again hall
for Edmonson to the Speedy McLoud crossing the
Blue Line McLoud hway and a stop by just Smith
H to Fogle back to hallway park behind the net to
the point Bard gets the puck back for the Oilers
dry Sidle Waits gets it back here's McDavid the
Smith is there the rebound available back on to
the Icees heroni a minute to go now it's five on
four dry SLE Waits passes off McDavid takes a look
one timer from Ayman stopped by just Smith 4.1
seconds to go here face off victory for Edmonton
can they get a shot on that no they cannot the
kxs what a start for Vancouver to this season